this week on quad Riga Syrian nightmare
countdown to intervention US officials
say they're now certain Bashar
al-assad's government troops are
responsible for chemical attacks last
week the un special envoy to Syria has
confirmed that the attack appears to
have killed hundreds of men women and
children on the outskirts of Damascus
Western leaders are determined to
respond but Russia and Iran have warned
against taking military action what
consequences will strikes have to
radical Islamist and to benefit most and
with the civil war in Syria really end
of Assad's government fell your host
this week Ali Aslan hello and welcome to
quadriga the United States and its
Western Allies are getting ready to
strike President Assad but the question
on everyone's mind of course is what
repercussions will such a strike have
not only in Syria but also abroad and
that's exactly what we're going to talk
about on today show together with three
individuals who've been following events
in Syria very closely welcome to fawaz
Telo who is part of the of Syria secular
opposition movement he's been living in
exile in germany since 2012 from 2001 to
2006 he was imprisoned by the Assad
regime Stefan bhuvan is with the German
network ard the reports frequently from
the Middle East and the Arab world and
Allison smell the Berlin bureau chief of
the New York Times she's been with the
time since 1998 and previously served as
the executive editor of the
International Herald Tribune welcome to
you all much to talk about very critical
times in Syria Allison smell the United
States says this undeniable proof
undeniable proof that President Assad
has used chemical weapons against its
own people would you agree is that also
your understanding I think it's hard for
those of us who do not have access to US
intelligence to know whether we can make
that judgment or not and
saying that the shadow of Iraq really
does hang over this debate and I
actually remember being in New York the
day that colon Powell went made his
famous presentation to the United
Nations in 2003 which later turned out
to be not exactly as he had presented
and he himself felt betrayed I think we
can say by a combination of whoever put
that presentation together so this is
tricky staff at the same time the cry
goes up something outrageous seems to
have happened in Syria hundreds of
people are dead there is a call for
action if the United States wants to
show that it is the world's biggest
military power which would undyed
undeniably is how can it use that power
and to influence events and to express
the outrage that for instance the German
Foreign Minister is called this a crime
against civilization which i think is a
way to sort of carp put a cast on the
debate that the Germans would prefer not
to discuss military action the British
and the French seem ready to join the
Americans in some sort of limited action
but David Cameron clearly mindful of
Tony Blair not having gotten
parliamentary approval for the war in
Iraq has called Parliament back and
wants to get parliamentary approval for
whatever he does if I'm one of course
there's no way for us here indeed to
verify whether or not such a chemical
attack was took place or rather was
perpetrated by us are but what is
certainly not in question it seems not
even by the Russians is that such an
attack did take place doctors without
borders are saying they treated over
3,000 patients with neurotoxic symptoms
of whom 355 people died and even the
Russians even the Russians say yes it's
probably most likely that such an attack
took place but the Russians are placing
the blame on the opposition what do you
make of this just a tactic to distract I
think the different parties the Russians
from the one side on the ones
and the Americans on the other side the
West on the other side they are playing
the political game now Russia has been
supporting Assad since the beginning of
the crisis and the West has been
supporting the opposition so it's a
revival of a cold war atmosphere and now
the Russians are using that shadow miss
Allison pointed to of a cast by the Iraq
war and the case made of supposed
weapons of mass destruction in in the
hands of Saddam Hussein came out untrue
so now the Russians in my view are using
this these doubts to blame the
opposition but okay as you say this
seems to be undeniable proof that
chemical weapons were used in east of
Damascus but we don't have undeniable to
prove about the perpetrators but of
course it seems more likely that these
chemical weapons were used by the regime
because the question is how the
opposition could possibly have access to
these weapons the argument the Russians
put forth flowers Telo is that President
Assad would not have used chemical
weapons against its own people while UN
inspectors were already in Syria you
inspectors were already in Syria when
this attack took place and the Russians
are saying even Assad is not that
reckless to do so in front of the very
eyes of the inspectors what's your point
I think Assad is so confident that
because since three years till now
nothing guys happen to him let me remind
you that we have before mr. kofi annan
inspection inspection people was there
in Syria and he commits already
committed crimes with the attendance of
the of that observers also we have it
the committee for the Arab League also
the Yanni murders have been committed so
it's it's part he was fully calm
fitness by the way the chemical rules
have been used for about 14 year times
before in some small points with life
and the opposition was all the time
taking asking for investigation
inspectors to come to a to cover it and
they were were fully cooperate with that
but like there is no dinner deniable
that the last attack about 1700 people
has been killed those people did not
suicide those people the Apollo here
Andy the opposition don't have the like
you said the material and this technique
to do what is happening but it's not
something you can bite from the
supermarket the K the chemical weapons
yeah hey it needs some procedures for
that and thus the opposition didn't kill
their people just to do to accurately
the regime the regime has been
forgivable for for for a long time 42
years over two years now of crimes and
he was fully confident that it will pass
and actually what's happening in the
last attack it was part of a military
attack on the countryside of Damascus so
it's part of a million military attack
is not just for killing people he was
wanted to get that area and Allison
small with the possible exception of
Russia and Iran the international
community pretty much subscribes to the
notion that President Assad has used
chemical weapons against its own people
and in doing so has crossed the famous
red line that President Obama set forth
in hindsight now his hands are tied the
pressure is on him his credibility is
very much at stake do you think it was
wrong of President Obama back then to
put forth such a red line I think it's
always really difficult to tell whether
you you draw a red line publicly or you
draw it in private if he if it was only
drawn in private let's imagine he had
not said this
but this attack had happened hundreds of
civilians are dead the outrage around
the world would would still have been
there the pressure would still be there
on the United States to act in my view
but it really is just my personal view I
think that discussing whether mr. Obama
was right or wrong to speak of a red
line is really to blur the true debate
which is are we going to take some
military action or not and if we do what
are the consequences have we weighed in
all sorts of repercussions or not and
how do we plan to i mean if as the talk
is of launching cruise missiles to spell
against specified sites probably in and
around damascus and that is an action
that lasts let's say two or three days
what has it achieved if it takes place
and what happens if something you know
sounds an odd thing to say goes wrong
but if a civilian target is struck i
mean i think we saw very quickly even
after nine eleven tremendous outpouring
of solidarity around the world for the
united states what about a month into
the conflict in Afghanistan as soon as a
Red Cross center was struck you know a
lot of Europeans were immediately are
you see the United States doesn't know
how to wage war and this is an
unjustified use of military power it's a
tricky one it's a tricky one Shivan let
me just point the following in fact out
that some people the argument that some
people have suggested they're saying
over a hundred thousand people have
already been killed in this conflict in
Syria and now chemical attacks have been
used against its own people by President
Assad what has changed at the end of the
day for president or for President Obama
hundred thousand people have already
been killed what's so different about
this chemical attack about the three
hundred casualties now that the u.s. is
deciding to step in okay a year ago we
were discussing here
the approximate end of the Assad regime
when an attack was carried out against
his security officials leading security
officials in Damascus and I said then
that we are facing an ever-escalating
war and this is not the end yet and I
think the use of chemical weapons is
another step in this ever escalating war
I think that you're the West could argue
to the dead it doesn't matter how they
were being killed I won't argue that I
wanted to make another point the Western
the international community as a whole
including Russia and China failed in one
thing they failed in reining in the this
escalation there was no credible threat
against the Assad regime from the
beginning of this crisis to show him we
are ready to use force if you cross over
some critical steps like the use of
chemical weapons and there was not such
a credible threat build up by the west
by the Obama administration at the first
point his talk about the red red lines
was not taken seriously by Syrian
decision-makers so that's one reason why
we see now this use of chemical weapons
and the question is if there is now a
symbolic strike by cruise missiles or
other military means against some
targets in Syria what will be the
outcome maybe the message will be ok now
we send the message that you must not
use chemical weapons but please go on
with the war and indeed fostelo the
White House press secretary has already
said that the strikes if they were to
occur are not about regime change that
is not the aim and mission of the united
states rather supposed to be limited
punitive strikes and no intervention
no ground troops that has been ruled out
from the get-go so the question it begs
indeed the question what will those
punitive limited strikes what could they
accomplish actually this is taking us
back why this what's happening happening
listen before 11 year we have a very
huge massacre in daraya just small town
beside the maskers 2,000 people have
been killed but there have been not with
Michael chemical level but have unity
they have been shooted or slaughtered
before few of you have used a few month
is we have about 2,000 people in the
costs have been also massacred or
shooting so it's not matter of how many
casualties or is it like you said this
and it's why I think and this will
answer your question what's happening
now that mr. Obama is feeling impressed
because for this red line which I'm sure
he is regret that he just talked about
it before and there is a lot of pressure
inside the American administration the
Congress for mr. Obama to do a reaction
so he have to do something at but he
want to be to be limited y tu to the
Paris I think what's happening first of
all is the impression of mr. Obama
second it's to weaken a little there is
a little bit military but we came so
much politically so you can pull him to
that to an advocate negotiating table in
the Indonesia but the third reason I
think it's very important the refugee
issue is very important look Jordan is
facing a catastrophe now and they are
they are facing a possibility of
collapsing with the regime because of
first of the refugee
a problem there shortland is very
sensitive and fragile country
economically politically socially what's
happening now about twenty percent of
the jordanian population is CVG and we
have now about 1.5 million refugee in
the countryside of Damascus which have
been under the attack most possible
possible those people especially if it
have been repeated with people will
leave to to Jordan this is the one of
the main reason which just I think in
the back which puts the American to do
something it's not that the chemical
loophole it's not the victims it's the
refugee issue which which will and one
man that Turkey I say I think don't
don't have this any kind of problem but
they can use that executes of the
refugee to make an interview this is
what they were arguing since about two
years ago and turkey of course is one of
those countries who have already pledged
their support for the United States
Allison smell and so has the UK in fact
the UK has put forth the UN Security
Council resolution authorizing necessary
measures to protect civilians and the
argument goes again do we need does the
United States and its Western Allies do
they need a UN mandate to strike against
Syria if you were to ask the Russians of
course they're saying any action without
a UN mandate would be a violation of
international law would you agree well I
think there's a lot of things that have
been bandied about in the last few days
as part of a discussion one is what is
the comparison here on what basis does
one take action or not take action one
comparison that's been used is Kosovo
because that's an example of where the
United States and its allies took action
but without UN Security Council backing
because again Russia was allied with the
Serbs and felt that it couldn't endorse
this kind of action also I mean if you
take that comparison further I'm not
sure it's a good one because the bombing
involved
making targets in downtown belgrade for
instance I don't think anybody is
talking here about a bombing campaign
against government installations in
downtown Damascus then the next point is
that the some people are arguing that
the chemical weapons convention from
1925 would give the legal mandate to act
here because you've got to make sure
that this is enforced and that chemical
weapons are not used in conflict it
seems like a fairly thin cover if you
like I think you know we face the
eternal question and certainly this came
up during World War two you're faced
with evidence of an outrage what do you
do and to what extent can you base your
action on moral and political
considerations to what extent you need
international law and the other thing I
just would would point out is that the
Russians have been very consistent in
this conflict in that they are backing
Assad but they're not saying that he
actually will stay there forever
Arabists in the old Soviet Union and in
Russia now were considered very much the
creme de la creme of the diplomatic
corps they have several people who speak
really good arabic and have great
contacts in the arab world their view is
you don't change horses in midstream
they were horrified when the United
States dropped support from Mubarak in
Egypt not because they love Mubarak but
because they think in this region you
stick with the with the person that you
have always backed now obviously there
are also other considerations for Russia
thousands and thousands of Russians
living in Syria who they've beginning to
evacuate now a warm water port and just
the sheer weight of historical ties so
it's not just kind of willful we're
going to not do what the Americans want
I mean in fact I think you see that john
kerry and lavrov the Russian Foreign
Minister
have been in close contact for several
months trying to get a negotiation going
in Geneva and I don't think that all of
those things were just sort of
shadowboxing I think there was some
Authority there well whether a UN
mandate is forthcoming or not is yet to
see but what seems to be rather certain
is that a strike is imminent the United
States seems very much determined to
send a message to President Assad
putting most people around the world on
the edge discussing this very nature
discussing this very topic worldwide
let's have a look on the streets of
Moscow many Russians say they stand
behind their government support for the
Assad regime in the one makin say the
Americans have no right to intervene
it's up to the Syrians to decide things
for themselves not opes the Americans
have intervened all over the world yes
yes the photograph at this point people
get involved from outside it only serves
to intensify conflict I think military
intervention should be an absolute last
resort though stammers a tweet after
over a decade of military action in Iraq
and Afghanistan many Americans are weary
of war I think there's other people in
the area who maybe should intervene
before people in this country get
involved I would rather see the United
Nations intervene but i do think
intervention is warranted fearing their
country could be drawn into the war
hundreds of israelis lined up to collect
gas masks in Jerusalem
Israeli citizens are panicking
unfortunately the Israeli military was
trying to avoid a state of panic is not
adjusted it serviced accordingly it's a
bit of a surreal experience I've never
been in this situation before so it's a
little bit exciting admittedly but it's
very it is very terrifying and I just
really pray that he's never going to
really need it well chef a muffin we
just saw some concern Israeli citizens
and by all accounts it's that concern is
justified isn't it because Iran is has
made very clear that any attack any
attack on Syria will be retaliated with
the strike on Israel what do you make of
this okay I would like to stress that
the people who basically is suffering
from this was the Syrian people with
millions of refugees and more than
100,000 dead people and it's obvious
that citizens of all the surrounding
countries are concerned as well
including the people of Israel and it's
very natural that the Israeli government
term is trying to protect its citizens
by dispatching gas masks knowing very
well that the Syrian regime possesses
chemical weapons and the ability to
launch missiles with equipped with
chemical weapons on a far distance so
but Israel has other means of protecting
itself there's a shield an anti-missile
shield which seems to be working so it's
natural that they take some measures of
quotient and protection but I don't
expect an escalation with sense of a
wedding exchange of missiles or air
attacks between Israel and Syria we have
to we have to remember that Israel
interfere did interfere several times
this year in this war but in the in my
view the targets were Hezbollah convoys
Hezbollah has had been um
stocking arms on syrian territory
territory considering that these
Arsenal's are secure there but this was
a consideration dating from before the
war in Syria and now Hizballah tries to
transfer these arms stocks to Lebanon
and Israel wants to prevent them from
doing so just so far if I just clarify
you're saying the threat on the part of
Israel you don't on the part of Iran
visa V Israel you don't deem to be
credible I didn't mention Iran yet I
mentioned Hizballah and I point to the
fact that his boa tries to transfer arms
stocks from Syrian territory to Lebanese
territory so obviously there is the
possibility of Hezbollah opening a new
front against Israel as part of this war
I mean we have to we are facing a
situation situation which is very very
unclear and difficult maybe everything
will be that will end with some symbolic
strikes on military targets in Syria by
the Americans and then and they go on
with their war within Syria and maybe it
will be the beginning of World War 3 we
don't know and if Iran is drawn in this
and Israel will retaliate any attacks by
Hizbollah on Haifa or other places in
Israel so there is potential for a huge
escalation and indeed the geographical
situation is quite delicate foristell oh
but nowhere is the situation as delicate
and severe as in Syria itself of course
which leads me to the question because
you still have friends in Syria you have
family you're still in touch with them
how is the announcement on the part of
President Obama to finally take action
against President Assad how is that this
news being perceived back home back in
Syria actually the main concern from
some people who still lived lives in the
under the regime in the regime area is
that most people they don't want to be
attacked otherwise they don't care about
what's blocking
in the other side for the refugee for
those people who has been suffering all
of them that they are they are welcoming
this kind of attacks butts but all of
all those of those people even those
people who's fighting on the ground
believe that the that this attack is has
a limited purpose so it's not for get
rid of the regime s part very
complicated the only issue in the end
though but let me have make a focus on a
point what's happening now with this
slag I think it's just opening a door
this Endora any box which you can't
expect what's really happening unless
you know the action and direction from
the other side I don't think the Iranian
will will attack the again used to use
their arms in the in the in the region
especially dimensions of Hezbollah and
and some people in some of those people
in Iraq but they will not interfere
directly there nobody will attack Israel
this is my own my opinion maybe some
this pro-palestinian groups will be
launched some rockets here or there for
for the Israeli and some at some point
but it's would be nothing but in this
case so the main battle will be it will
still in Syria what will happen after
this after this this is what will give
you how I'm going to explain it I expect
that we will we will see another attacks
in the coming future it's not continuous
attacks but but according so for a
special political and sometimes military
agenda to push forward for for for a
political solution or to give more
messages for the regime that he should
not cross the red line it's not a big
chemical weapons only the red lines it's
attacking the struggle for the red lines
for the for the world so he and i think
the regime understand this kind of red
line and Alison smell now that President
Assad seems to have cross
that red line some US security officials
are only cautiously applauding if you
will the move or the announcement on the
part of President Assad because they're
saying that the attack on Syria and on
president of Assad at the end of the day
might benefit radical Islamists because
as we know some Syrian rebel factions
have ties to al-qaeda and there are
voices out there particularly in the
United States who say yes of course we
want to get rid of us so we want to end
this conflict but we are also fearing
the possibility of ending up with if you
will other individuals who are not
exactly you know favorable to us as well
what do you make of it I mean I think
Stefan hit the point and also your
consideration of how people feel inside
Syria and we are looking at an
unpredictable situation here ever since
the so-called Arab Spring began what two
and a half years ago the region has
become definitely less predictable and
more volatile than it had been for many
decades I think that the United States
obviously there's a clear reluctance to
stir more trouble for itself at the same
time how do you maintain your influences
Irv as a world power if you don't
actually get involved in the region the
other thing that I think has been quite
little discussed particularly here in
Germany where the election campaign the
tendency seems to be to keep all issues
possibly away from it so I think one
thing that is not being considered very
much is an unpredictable simmering
Middle East is bound to produced many
refugees inevitably many of those people
will try to reach Europe have we
considered at all what we would what we
would do I mean last week in Berlin we
saw tremendous popular opposition to the
moving of a few hundred refugee foreign
refugees into some public facilities in
the eastern part
of Berlin I just don't feel as if this
debate has has been sort of tied
together at all and you know world war
three sounds apocalyptic but we have to
be realistic that weapons are doing the
talking in several parts of the region
we've also seen what has happened in
Egypt and it's we should be prepared for
a repro long period of certainly
unsettled well two and a half years of
conflict in within Syria and possibly
more within and outside as well let's
talk about Germany here seven move on at
the end of the day it's not only the
u.s. of course its Western Allies that
you can father very much rallied around
President Obama and Germany's in the
midst of an election campaign in a month
from now there's going to be a huge and
important election campaign coming up
here in Germany chance of miracle is
Germany's voice important here as you
know Germany's voice is not important
and you know that there's a use
reluctance among the government foreign
ministry and also Chancellor Merkel with
regard to interfering militarily in any
conflict in the world and this is true
also concerning conflict in Syria you
said that there's a debate there should
be a debate which is absent from the
public scene concerning the refugee
issue and prospect of many refugees
arriving here you I agree with you that
this is not part of the public debate
but I can assure you that this is the
only and main issue being discussed
within German government circles they
are they don't air it out they don't
they don't talk about military
interference they don't talk about
strategic interests and the Middle East
they are talking about how can we keep
all these refugees away and they are
taking measures against this this is the
main issue concerning German decision
like
decision makers have all have made a
decision back then in Libya to stay out
and it has cost some than some
sympathise with their NATO allies in
particular do you think Germany can run
the risk once more to stay out if such a
strike would occur I mean when we look
at the issue Syria there are strong
reasons of not interfering militarily so
this decision by the German government
is not so hard to to argue for because
the outcome of any military strike in
Syria is very unclear and I there are
some people now some voices which I
would say are coming out of conspiracy
theories that the Americans are looking
for pretext to interfere this is just
untrue because if Obama had been looking
for a pretext he would have found one a
long time ago so all the the aim of of
mobile obama has been not to interfere
in syria and staying away as well obama
is not interested in the Middle East he
looks at the Middle East as a region and
with problems it's a barrel of problems
so he puts his emphasize and political
and geostrategic priorities on the Asian
Pacific area and and militarily
economically politically so now against
his own will he is confronted with the
choice of may be interfering militarily
in Syria and the outcome is very unclear
because it the chaos will increase in
Syria and I mean you pointed at the
prospect of me killing civilian people
innocent people with such strikes I mean
very easily military interference in
Syria could in one or day or two kill
more civilian people than were killed by
these outrageous chemical attacks of you
last week so
it's not easy so if I was hello let's
let's assume the strikes will take place
I think it is understood even among
military experts and security officials
that these punitive limited strikes will
of course not lead to asad's removal
what will at the end of the day two and
a half years into this conflict more
than hundred thousand people dead close
to two million refugees in Syria which
you mentioned the very dire situation in
neighboring countries at the end of the
date when two and a half years a long
time what will remove Assad at the end
of the day what will end this conflict
arming the opposition or to having a
real a real strong message from the
international community from the
American and European especially that we
are going to get reg of you personally
if you are if you didn't leave Syria
this is what I have been putting on I I
said that few before he wanted in
quadriga here like we had the
international commission give him a real
as very strong message not only for him
for the military apparatus which support
him which mainly it's from a Louis
balloons like they have to understand
that this person and this phone is over
from from the political life so in this
case you can you can give the right
message for those people maybe to have a
coup or to make a real pressure against
them to get rid of em in and and in this
case only we can start a political
process with Bashar Assad this only you
can't start a political process I think
this attack is giving that message for
the people who is supporting Bashar
Assad in and they can't stand it because
actually they don't they are really
afraid of a real reduction from that
from the American of special event from
the European and I want to come
took a little about extremists in Syria
like look before 11 and a half year we
don't have an extremist in Syria as long
as this this crisis is taking more time
we will have motivated the member the
main problem we have is Bashar Assad
himself if you get rid of a shot I said
now it's better than to get rid of him
in the future he can't be a partner not
now in the future so you understand the
fears on the part of Western nations
though who say Assad is the devil we
know we don't know who will replace him
we already was seeing what what's
replacing the curse inside Syria which
is going and start to spread it all over
the region this is the main devil it's
not only for some few of the Islamic
switch this small group is extremist
just right now there is a tag there is
clashes between them and Free Syrian
Army the clashes between them and the
civilian in the area where were they
attend to the Syrian people did accept
this phenomenon in general to get rid of
Bashar Assad this is the the main point
to get rid of the of what's going and by
the way p part of change to be part of
those people who is going sit on the
table and decide the future of Syria
otherwise you can't just sit back aside
and said I and give some advices you're
here and there and let what's happening
just happening there in this course is
taking over we already have a cure
stress but the kills will be more more
and more in the future Alison smell has
in the United States and its Western
Allies waited too long to take action
here I think you it's that's an
impossible question to answer give it it
cuz well I mean what you point out your
argument is very strongly that the
removal of Bashar Assad would would move
towards a solution I think that's
difficult to calculate because he has
been able to hold on for two and a half
years he clearly has some support from
which he can draw within
Syrian society within Syrian elite every
time somebody has major has defected
we've debated the idea that oh perhaps
now the circle around him is crumbling
it doesn't seem to be and you can debate
you know would Russian withdrawal of
Russian support make a difference I I
think we don't know the answer to any of
these questions and what we haven't so
far seen is a United political and
diplomatic will outside of Syria to
decide on here's what we want out of
this and here's how we're going to get
there I just don't think that we've
we've seen that Chef Anne Boleyn what is
the scenario you hear that we're looking
at of course we're speculating here but
what is the possible scenario after the
US and its Western Allies destroy
President Assad I come back to the point
of the other escalating war and an
increasing chaos I think asher scenario
is that we are facing a dying nation and
this is a very sad fact if you know
Syria and had traveled in Syria you know
you would know all the the richness the
civilizational roots the diversity all
this is dying and I'm afraid that this
death cannot be avoided any more it's a
crumbling nation it's falling apart and
it will be virtually impossible in my
view to put it together again fostelo
very pessimistic worse from Stefan bukan
do you share that sentiment are you
fearing about the future you're fearing
for the future of your nation perhaps
even the possibility that such a state
called Syria will not exist in the
future sea-level exists in future and
not just the uneasy not to hope but but
we need sometimes to recover what's
happening and I think this is a very
important rule for the international
community including the Arabs and the
ways to be part of that reconciliation
which should take up in but it will
start with justice you can make any kind
of consolation without a justice this
justice could be just be a huge and very
strong justice and bit and could be
merciful just this depends on how we can
get directive the regime firstly as long
as and how to get rid of the regime is
also very much on the mind of President
Obama and its Western Allies these days
the whole world is watching this events
unfold especially in New York the
Security Council and we will see what
will happen in the next days and weeks
to come we will of course follow the
story here at DW very intensely in the
meantime I want to thank my guess for a
very spirited discussion at times
pessimistic I want to thank you out
there for watching see you next week
you
you